photogrammetry is the process of
stitching together hundreds sometimes
thousands of high-res digital images
into one complete 3d model
every single one of these objects are
completely fake and the result of the
photogrammetry process i use these photo
scans to build or populate my 3d
environments and some people use this
technique to actually archive historical
or sentimental items it's a great way to
achieve photoreal detail without
spending days or weeks manually modeling
and texturing an entire object or
location and having your own library of
unique 3d scans will ultimately make
your art feel more unique which might be
one of the most important things for 3d
artists so in this video i'm going over
the ins and outs of photo scanning
starting with a detailed guide on how to
take clean photos of your object how to
process your images to get the most out
of them and finally i'll show you how to
align those images turn that point cloud
into a mesh texture your mesh and export
various levels of detail all from a
program called reality capture the
sponsor of today's video so stick around
to the end of this video to figure out
how you can get 10 worth of credits and
start scanning today so you can scan
just about anything that stays still it
can be as small as a tiny little rock to
an entire cliff face i got started with
small stuff like this cactus or a
pumpkin but eventually got comfortable
with larger objects so in this video
i'll walk you through my process on this
one wheel now i must warn you once you
get the hang of the scanning process
you'll get super addicted and want to
scan everything it's kind of the best so
no matter what program you're using to
process your scans taking clean
well-exposed images is the most
important part of the photogrametry
process without enough clean images
you'll either have a chunky scan or no
scan at all so it's crucial that your
images are in focus with no motion blur
have enough light and maintain
consistent settings all the way through
so we want to shoot entirely manual and
once you get your camera set up don't
change those settings because it'll just
throw off the process later if you start
zooming in or adding iso for darker
areas the only thing that's auto in this
case is our focus if you're shooting on
a smartphone you'll want to use an app
that lets you tweak as many settings as
possible namely exposure white balance
shutter speed and aperture but to get
the most out of my scans i'm shooting on
my 42 megapixel sony a7r ii in raw
format so let's just pretend for a
moment that your camera is a flashlight
revealing new parts of your object as
you take pictures if you can shine light
into every crevice you'll have the
cleanest scan in the end the larger
variety of images you have of a single
reference point the better your
photogrammetry software can agree on
that point's position in 3d space
ultimately producing a higher fidelity
scan so the easiest way to ensure you're
covering your entire object with enough
overlap is to simply follow the shape of
that object at various levels of
elevation so for my one wheel or any
object really i'll start about level
with its midpoint at my close up or
detailed distance and snap pictures on
the way back to my wide distance
shooting pictures as we move backwards
ensures our close-up shots have a bridge
to our wide shots if we change the angle
or distance too much between any of
these photos we're taking today you
won't have enough overlap for your
photogrammetry software to stitch those
images together once we've made it to
our wide distance i'll take a baby step
in either direction doesn't matter and
snap a shot move another baby step take
another picture until we've made it all
the way around our entire object on
average 12 to 15 photos per quarter is
ideal for these size scans so i'm
counting while i move if i can keep my
photo count in that zone i know i'm
shooting enough pictures with enough
overlap to generate a clean scan any
less and your scan would just look
blocky or worse lack the data necessary
to align the images you'd have to go
back and reshoot and sometimes that's
just not possible bonus tip for you when
you're scanning large walls you can
shoot what's called a stereo pair two
pictures of the same point from two
angles two stereo pairs look like this
and it's how i shot out this cactus wall
so once our first loop is complete i'll
adjust my elevation a little bit making
sure to maintain my distance from the
object then shoot another series of
photos all the way around once complete
do another pass from a slightly higher
elevation and so on until you're nearly
shooting straight down onto your model
the more you scan the less you'll have
to think about all this stuff and you
might just realize hey maybe i'm taking
too many photos chances are in the
beginning you're not taking enough but
there's only one way to find out and
that's just to hop in and get scanning
all right but what about the underside
of this thing very carefully without
jostling any individual bits i'll flip
over my onewheel and shoot those photos
out again capturing the entire bottom
side of my one wheel once that's done
i'll do each side as well for extra
coverage and with that i should have
enough detail to piece this entire thing
together in reality capture note that we
could return to our detail or close-up
angle to once again trace the contour of
our object and really get in the cracks
for the highest quality but we'll be
fine with what we just shot out two
crucial notes on lighting before we move
on you want your object to be evenly lit
with soft light so you're not pre-baking
any harsh light into your scan you can
either set up bounce light like i'm
doing here for my wheel or shoot outside
in the shade or during overcast weather
this way we can drop our scans into any
3d environment regardless of the
lighting and finally i'm using a lens
filter it's called a polarizer and i'm
using it to cut down on reflections it's
not absolutely necessary but makes for
cleaner more de-lit scans if you're
taking it super seriously so now that we
have a butt ton of images let's hit some
yoga poses real quick to fix our broken
back our jacked up shoulders because
honestly photo scanning it takes a toll
on your body but let's hop into an image
editing software to batch process these
images so i'm using lightroom for batch
adjustments but you all can use whatever
you'd like for this step now it's not a
necessary step but it makes a pretty big
difference in my opinion so let's import
our images and clean one up since i shot
raw let's make sure we start with the
raw image as opposed to the color
corrected one so i'll click on this
profile right here camera standard
browse all profiles and under adobe raw
select adobe neutral which displays our
raw image from here i'll return to the
edit tab
and i'll boost the exposure as needed
brighten up our shadows lower our whites
and highlights and finally get rid of
any subtle noise we might have from the
adjustments we just made now besides
making things a bit brighter these
adjustments are flattening out our image
in order to de-light things even further
because again we want our 3d environment
to decide the lighting conditions of
these models i'll click the all images
view and copy the settings from this
image select everything with control a
and paste onto all the others let's make
sure every image is selected again go to
file export and original size jpegs will
be perfect now since we shot out four
views of this onewheel we'll process
each view as an individual scan and then
combine them together later so i've
split our images into top bottom side
one and side two folders if you didn't
flip your object over to reveal the
underside or simply couldn't for
whatever reason throwing them all into a
processed folder will do the trick so
now it is finally time to open reality
capture and process this onewheel scan
let's do it first let's change our view
by clicking any one of these buttons on
the top left and i'll drag my top data
set into the blank space here i prefer
to work in 1d view as i can see more
info on my images and create control
points which we'll get to in just a
minute now let's click on the alignment
tab and select align images and after a
few minutes you should have a point
cloud representation of your object each
one of these white boxes is the specific
image being referenced it's actually
pretty sweet to see now if for whatever
reason it looks incomplete or jacked up
in any way check if your model was split
into various components on the left if
you see multiple components it's because
there wasn't enough overlap between one
part of your data set and another this
usually happens to me when i get
impatient and skip too far in elevation
or something and it'll likely happen to
you as you're getting the hang of things
you'll either need to take more photos
retake blurry photos or manually set
control points all with the goal of
helping reality capture bridge your
separate components together and i'll go
over the details of that workflow in
just a bit when we talk troubleshooting
so once our images are aligned you'll
notice a light gray box around your
point cloud if not you can navigate to
tools and click set reconstruction
region and we'll want to tighten it down
around our model because that's the area
reality capture is going to process i
don't want to mesh my entire garage in
this case just the one wheel so let's
drag these colored buttons until the box
fits around the wheel and you can use
numpad 1-7 to make this a bit easier
from here in our mesh model tab let's
click normal detail to mesh our point
cloud now this can take a while if you
have a ton of high-res images that
you're working with this is about a 15
to 20 minute process for me on my
current rig but this looks great as far
as the top of this one wheel is
concerned so what we want to do is
export masks so we can combine the top
bottom side one and side two
of our onewheel in a separate project
file but first we need to cut out
anything from this top view that's not
the object we're trying to scan in this
case the apple boxes i'm using to prop
up my onewheel and to make this easier
let's go to tools and click set ground
plane work the gizmo to straighten
things out and now let's hit rec for the
rectangular selection tool and four on
the numpad to enter a side view i'll
select this side
and holding control i'll select the
other side and click filter selection to
delete the unwanted geometry now we're
all set to export our masks under the
meshing tab we can select depth and
masks to export a series of masks that
correlate to every single image we just
need to direct the images to our top
folder
and disable the depth option and you'll
notice a bunch of black and white masks
that correspond to each photo so let's
repeat this step for the bottom side
we'll save this as top open a new
project and drag our bottom images in f6
to align nice
and control f7 to mesh let's get rid of
the geometry that isn't our object under
tools let's grab our rectangular
selection tool select that geometry and
filter selection finally we'll export
our masks by clicking depth and masks
and save them in the bottom folder do
this until you have masks for every side
of your object but once you have all
your masks for all your sides it's time
for the best part where we bring all of
these images together into one complete
scan so let's drag and drop our top
bottom side one and side two folders
into a new project and if you click on
an image you'll notice they're each
referencing a unique mask image perfect
now we pray that reality capture aligns
these images in one go heck yeah this
looks awesome we got all four sides on
the first try i had to scan like six to
eight objects in order to do this in one
go otherwise i was manually combining
components with control points which
again i'll show you after we mesh and
texture so to turn this point cloud into
a mesh let's navigate to the meshing tab
and choose our detail level you can
experiment with other levels of detail
here but normal is more than enough with
a 42 megapixel camera that's mesh by
clicking mesh model or pressing f7
beautiful this looks fantastic tons of
detail throughout this model and if you
could imagine going even further you can
return to that close-up angle like i
talked about earlier shoot those out for
every side as well and use them to mesh
in texture but let's just texture this
thing right now by either pressing
texture or hitting f9 and after a few
minutes we have one beautiful highly
detailed evenly lit one wheel scan ready
to be dropped into a 3d scene in any
program you want i still need to show
you how to export this thing properly so
hang tight as promised though let's
solve the number one problem 3d scanners
will run into in reality capture
like i mentioned earlier if your scans
get separated into multiple components
is because you either didn't take enough
images you move too much between your
images or your pictures may be too dark
blurry or noisy if reshooting isn't an
option you'll need to manually set
control points so in 1d view let's drop
down control points and create a control
point we should also change our layout
so we can pull multiple images at once
i'll pick a small visual mark that's
visible across a series of images on
both components i'll drop my first
control point there and from a different
angle i'll drop the same control point
on the same mark
and usually after two or three images
reality capture will auto find that mark
in as many images as possible so you
want to go through each one check it and
say yep add that control point i'll do
this for a handful of images in
component zero and add it to a handful
of other images in component one and
usually with two to four control points
generally across all your components we
can merge them together by going to the
alignment tab then let's click merge
components if it's successful then
you'll get the full component in our 1d
list if it's a fail you'll get multiple
components again you can delete the ones
you don't need and keep adding points
until everything is merged this can be
the most time-consuming uninspiring part
of photogrammetry so please save
yourself time and focus on getting a
proper data set first and foremost i'd
rather be great at taking pictures
versus being a control point master but
trust me once you get the hang of this
photogrametry workflow you'll rarely be
setting control points so let's export
this thing so we can use it in any 3d
program we want i'll set the ground
plane first so our model imports at the
center point by going to the tools tab
selecting set ground plane and using the
gizmo to center it up as far as export
goes i like to do it from the mesh model
tab using the levels of detail option we
only have so much vram so exporting lods
lets us be smart about which version of
the model we're adding to our scene this
saves the model at decreasing levels of
detail starting with zero and so on
let's set the model count to choose how
many lods we're exporting five is
usually good for me save mesh by parts
nope we want it as one piece textures of
course and original size and png format
and boom you have five levels of detail
if you just need to export the high res
scan you can go to the workflow tab and
simply hit export and fbx will do the
trick save mesh by parts no export
textures yes a single texture yes indeed
and png format rocks now throw your
models into any scene you want using any
program you want and have fun adding
endless unique detail to your own custom
worlds scanning is the best and i am
officially addicted i hope you all have
as much fun as i'm having during this
process you can download reality capture
in the description for free use the code
punisher 100 to get 10 worth of points
to get scanning right now the ppi system
they have is cool because you only pay
on export for your total megapixel count
so you can scan and test as much as you
want until you're ready to use your
points and it's actually all pretty
affordable in the end also i want to
shout out william foshea's channel
because halfway through making this
video i found out william was doing a
video on photo scanning as well so we
managed to sync up and cover slightly
different topics for you guys if you
want to see how he scanned this cabin
click the link in the description below
and finally if you want to get your
hands on my onewheel scan and all the
other scans i made while honing my
workflow they're all up on my patreon
pro tier along with all my packs
textures and bts content y'all thank you
so much for watching this video thanks
for watching this channel this year it
has been a crazy year especially since
leaving corridor and leaning full time
into this channel
i have a ton of stuff that i want to get
into in 2022 and can't wait to knock it
out with y'all y'all have been so
supportive and i cannot thank you enough
for learning and growing with me it's
been amazing so let's keep learning
let's keep growing let's get scanning
and happy holidays to each and every one
of y'all i'll see you in 2022.
peace
if you want a photo scanning challenge
over the holiday break i'm running one
this week in my discord server the links
in the description
come hone your scanning workflow with us
it'll be a good time
[Music]